A one 80 88 to one 90 believe it or not.
Like for most people that are listening
to this that's on the light side. Yeah,
no, absolutely. I know it is,
but the thing is I'm solely and I'm on
80 and I'm walking around below 6% body
fat. You are. Wow. Who Do you use to cut
for weight? For the last couple of fights,
man, I've been working with uh, Clint,
Clint Wittenberg up at the Pii and
Trifecta. Yeah. And truly a lot.
Yeah. And Clinton make tremend trifecta
food system try effect essentially,
you know, the meal delivery, meal prep
stuff and they do a phenomenal job.
Phenomenal.
And Clint,
the reason I chose to go with him
is I've always did it by myself.
I like to cook, I cook for
myself. I always, you know,
when all those fights earlier fights
in the UFC, every one of my fights,
I was in charge of my own diet.
I cook for myself.
I do this because I've done it so many
years in wrestling, all the wrong way.
I can look at myself,
I can wake up in the morning and look at
myself in the mirror and tell how much
I weigh and I'd be right on just because
I'm so used to my body so I know what I
can or I can't eat what can hold food
or it can hold water and it's just,
it's a discipline thing for me as well.
And so I, so I decided, you know what,
I'm getting higher up now.
One thing that I don't understand is
that I haven't done the research is,
is what foods to eat before a certain
practice at certain times to feel me to
best to make me help,
help me feel the best because I'm
getting older and things aren't the same.
They use the way they see me.
I'm 31 and I'm gonna be 32 in May.
And I'm like, man, I just
don't fit differences.
Have you noticed a lot of difference?
Like at 24 I just fucking wake up at
6:00 AM and I can go for a freaking five
mile run like that with nothing.
Now I can do that anymore.
Do you think that his age or
do you think that is miles,
like all the hard training come into
combination because 31 year in your
athletic time? Yeah, it's a combination
of both because in wrestling years I,
I gotta be in late forties. He's
wrestling years. Am I late for it? I mean,
back is, are shot my, you
know, my shoulders are shot,
my knee, my knees. Oh my God, my knees.
I've had five knee surgeries and Jesus
Christ. Yeah, I saw you Olympian.
Did you have one recently?
I just had surgery actually.
Um, had surgery on Tuesday.
Oh, that's her. Susan had
a double hernia. Jesus.
Did you fight with a double hernia?
I tore it before.
I like five weeks before
the fight and I'm,
but I don't know if it was completely off.
You had a hernia and a broken foot.
Yeah. Fucking crazy.
The funny thing is, um,
Ollie makes fun of me about this.
My manager is like all fight week.
Like if you saw me,
you would think this guy was like
a Zombie. Like I, I limp around,
I freaking Lidacain patches
on me and I'm in a boot or,
or sleeve and all I do all day is I go
do the media around or whatever I need to
do training, come back and I'm just in
my room. I had a game ready on me or,
or something on me.
But when I walked through that door
to fight the 19 or nightmare wakes up,
I flipped the switch. And a
lot of people would, would,
if they'd go back and look at
videos of when I walk into the cage,
I stay separate before the cage.
I press him my prayer for protection and
when I walk in I just freaking don't,
if it's like a flip that switch
prayer that you say every time. Yeah,
the exact same thing. Yeah. What do you
say similar along those lines? I just,
I basically just a prayer for protection,
prayer for me to be able to
display the best of my abilities.
It's never, I, cause I'm not selfish.
It's not, I'm not getting in that prayer.
Please let me win. No, it's
please protect me in here.
So I can go back to my family safe and
sound and protect my opponent as well,
and give me the strength to be able
to display the best of my abilities.
And that's it. And once I
freaking walked through that door,
I'm the freaking Nigeria nightmare.
I just feel like a different person.
I am. I am. And you see it in
my face. Um, I'm good and dandy,
but when I walk in and it goes away, I've,
I just, I transform into that person.
Yeah.
I think a lot of people would be surprised
at how friendly and easygoing you are
outside. People can't tell. And that's the
thing now is there's really, I haven't,
I don't, I don't, there's no change in me.
I'm still the same freaking guy since
I haven't done anything since a fire,
nothing.
People were like asking me,
how have you gone on party in this
now with the bell and not have a dish?
He's like, no, my daughter, I bought
it from my daughter, my daughter.
But I didn't, I didn't do anything.
I just sit on the couch, watch TV,
go back, maybe go to the,
uh, the shop that I like to
take my daughter to get, uh,
get French toast. She loves this one
place. So I take her there, come back.
That's it. Or maybe take
her to a date. Nine.
The only difference is now people are
starting to recognize me more so like I'm
walking out the movies and people will
stop me. Hey, can I get a picture?
Can I get a picture? Yeah, of course.
You know, but nothing changed.
I'm the same freaking guy.
I haven't got a chance to do anything.
I had surgery last Tuesday.
I've been in bed for weeks,
so I haven't done anything, but I don't
think anything is going to change.
I'm the same guy. Well, you sound
like you have the perfect attitude.
Like the idea that you're having,
making a prayer to just do your best and
not be hurt and none of your opponent
hurt and protect you and your opponent.
That's, that was a beautiful attitude.
And the fact that the way you're
approaching this, I mean, you're just,
you're just here to compete and
to do your very best, all of you.
You're free of the burden of a lot of
bullshit that some people carry around
with them. You know, and I was thinking
about this on the way up as, um, a lot of,
a lot of those fighters, a lot of those
champions, like after a while you,
you there,
they feel this certain pressure to,
to be able to do this or that.
And some of the examples that I gave is
there's so much pressure. Edison silver,
I almost felt like he couldn't wait
to those. Yeah. He was just like,
it's like a pressure the way you
just want to put it down. Yeah.
When Bj Penn beat him. Yeah. It was just
so much want to get out is actually on,
I feel like you received,
it was so much pressure at Georgetown
peer ran away from the sport because of
that pressure. Yeah. You know, some
people, for me, I don't feel shit.
I was just, I was just thinking,
I was like, I don't care. Like,
look at this fight now that come in to
fight, right? Everyone's already bringing,
making a big deal out of it.
It's another fight for me.
I don't even think of myself as, oh,
you're the champion. I don't care.
I just want to beat this guy up.